لا اله الا الله
[Silence]
والسماوات
بسم الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما بعد
كين ان رياض الصالحين
في كتاب الملح في كتاب المنثورات والملح
الدجال المسيح الكذاب
يقول النووي رحمه الله تعالى وعن ابي
هريره رضي الله عنه
ابو هريره
عبد الرحمن بن صخر الدوسي
قال قال رسول الله
مسلم
خيبر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
نعم
قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم الا
احدثكم حديثا عن الدجال ما حدث به نبي
قومه
انه اعور وانه يجيء معه بمثال الجنه
والنار
فالتي يقول انها الجنه هي النار متفق عليه
وهذا الكلام يحمل على
حقيقته
وايضا
معناه
او دلالته المعنويه المجازيه
فهو ياتي
بمثال الجنه والنار فالتي يراها الناس جنه
هي نار
تتاجج والتي يراها الناس نارا هي جنه
حقيقه وايضا
معنويا
يعني
الذي يدعو الناس اليه من اتباعه
يهيئ
لاتباعه
ان هذا هو سبيل الجنه وسبيل الراحه وسبيل
الخير وسبيل الدعم
وفي الحقيقه هو سبيل العذاب والعكس صحيح
ابو هريره
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
that no proped
‏isent
will have him to both parad and fire and
peoplece
and tell people
ابن
اسمه
عبد الله ابن عمر ابو
حمزه
ابو عبد الرحمن ابو عبد الرحمن يقول عن
ابن عمر رضي الله عنهما ان رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم ذكر الدجال بين ظهراني
الناس يعني هو بين الناس ذكر الدجال فقال
ان الله ليس باعور الا ان المسيح الدجال
اعور العين اليمنى كان عينه عنبه طافيه
في بعض ضبطت هذه الكلمه طافيه بالهمزه
وبالياء
وكلاهما صحيح يعني طافئه
وطافيه
طافئه وطافيه
ابن عمريه
كان بين الناس
صلى الله
‏would
he had
audiences
and specific audiences and he had close
almost closed door meetings with
certain companions he would meet with
the schar among the companions and speak
to them in
‏is apprate and would masses would on
topics that apprate so not every
gathering was suitable for every toic
did he teach the way among people
said washer
[Silence]
رضي الله عنهم
الله
يقول ان الله ليس باعور
احنا ذكرنا امبارح ان العور في لغه العرب
لا يطلق الا على من عينان
احداهما
اي يعني معطله احداهما
طافئه او طافيه
فالعرب لا يطلقون
العوض في لغتهم الا على من عينان
فهو يقول هنا ان الله
ليس باعور هل هذا مدح هل هذا ثناء
على الله سبحانه وتعالى او لا
يقصد به الثناء
‏So when the prophet here says indeed
Allah is not
what me by this
is a praise of Allah subhanahu waala
corre what me is to exalt Allah with one
of his description and so we said and we
mentioned yesterday that the principle
is ‏that mere negation is not a form of
praise. Remember yesterday we talked
about this. So if I if I were to say for
instance I'm speaking about a person I
say this person is not a liar
that on its own is not praise. It's only
praise if I imply it's opposite
meaning this person is not a liar he is
truthful always.
والا فالنفي المحد ليس بثناء
نفي المحد
لا يكون الا براءه الذمه
[Silence]
ذلك الكتاب لاب
ر
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ليس باع
لان هذه
الروايه
من احاديث الصفات
اعتبرها العلماء من احاديث الصفات لذلك
اجمع الصحابه على اثبات العينين لله
سبحانه وتعالى
لكن
هاتا لكن هاتين العينين
هما
كسائر صفات الله نثبت الحقيقه ونثبت
المعنى وننفي الكيفيه عن الله سبحانه
وتعالى بمعنى ان الانسان لا يدرك كيفيه
صفات الله كسائر الصفات لله وجه ليس كوجوه
عباده الله اعلم
بكيفيه وجهه نثبت الوجه وننفي
ادراك الكيفيه كما قال الامام مالك رحمه
الله الاستواء معلوم والكيف غير معقول
والايمان به واجب والسؤال عنه بدعه كما
تواترت الروايات عن الامام مالك
المسيح الدجال
in
as
ep
in
a dimed
لايت
سو طافيه وطافئه
طافيه ام طافئه
بمعنى طايشه
يعني العنبه لو وضعتها في مثلا في كوب
الماء تجد العنبه تطيش
فهيناتئه
زي العنبه الطايشه فوق الميه
وهي ايضا طافئه بمعنى نورها مطفي
تعرف العين له العين
له نور
الميت اذا تشوف عينين الميت ما في نورانه
مات واضح
هذا عينه
طافئه ما فيها النور مطفيه
soز
‏isuding
and is out
is dim right
so now we have fewption
one of the description is wr
between eyes wr on face is
ك right anotherion
is right ey ‏is protruding and it is
dimmed. It has no light to it.
Another that we have taken of his
descriptions is that he has with him a
river of fire and a river of water and
these two rivers are exactly the
opposite of what they appear to be.
‏Another of his descriptions is that he
comes with a mountain of bread and a
river of
and so are all that
chosen from the vast body of
the
المسيح الدجال نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يعص صمنا من فتنه
المسيح الدجال وان يقينا عذاب النار وعذاب
القبر وان ا يحفظنا من فتنه المحيا
والممات والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد
[Silence]
الله
لما ياتي ‏H